[Musique]
Oh
c'est mon repaire secret
pas d'accord vomir comme ça appeler merci
beau costume visiter Stanley
[Musique]
oh Jésus oh ce n'est pas bon
non non non oh tu ne vas pas  éloignez-vous de
celui-là
oh c'est un tétras oh je suis vraiment désolé d'
accord j'ai passé trop de temps dans
la cabine téléphonique si je suis honnête avec
moi-même j'aurais probablement dû
appeler le 911 maintenant importe maintenant si je les lis
tous les deux
il y a  un vrai point ici alors [ __ ] c'est qu'une
cabine téléphonique fait disparaître un coin de rue
en 98 supposons que j'aurais pu
me disputer
whoo je suis la glace Jerry Garcia tu as besoin de
ça ne réponds pas maintenant c'est vrai et en
fait j'ai appelé le  le client
son nom est Larry m'a généralement aidé à mettre
ce costume sur les autres gars le faire si
vite qu'il ne serait probablement pas mort
si c'était Logan que vous deviez changer en
c'était un [ __ ] de débardeur de la paire de
jeans ouais long net get  mon débardeur un
peu d'inspiration avoir un joli petit
crime qui se bat depuis un an epi hugger
c  toute une journée
[Musique]